Divide.
Simplify the answer and write
as a mixed number.
And we have 2 and 1/4 divided
by 1 and 3/4.
So the first thing we want to
do since both of these are
mixed numbers is to
convert them both
into improper fractions.
So let's start with 2 and 1/4.
So we're still going to have
4 in the denominator, but
instead of 2 and 1/4,
remember, 2 is the
same thing as 8/4.
So we have 8/4, and then
we have another 1/4.
That gives us 9/4.
Or another way to come up with
this 9, you take 4 times 2,
which is 8, plus 1.
That gives you 9.
And then the 1 and 3/4,
same process.
You're going to have 4 in the
denominator, and then the
numerator is going to be 4 times
1, which is 4, plus 3,
which is 7.
So this is the exact
same problem here.
2 and 1/4 divided by 1 and 3/4
is the same thing as 9/4
divided by 7/4.
And we saw in several videos
already that dividing by a
fraction is the same thing as
multiplying by its reciprocal.
So this is equivalent to-- so
these are all equivalent.
This is equivalent to 9/4 times
the reciprocal of this.
We're changing the division
operation to a multiplication,
and we're taking the reciprocal
of the 7/4.
For the reciprocal of 7/4, you
swap the numerator and
denominator, or the top
number and the bottom
number, and you get 4/7.
Now, we could just
multiply these.
We could just say this is 9
times 4, which would be 36,
over 4 times 7, which is 28,
and then try to put it in
lowest terms, or we could do it
right now because it would
be simpler.
We have a 4 in the numerator.
We have a 4 in the denominator,
that'll
eventually be in the
denominator, so let's divide
our eventual numerators
and our eventual
denominators both by 4.
So you divide this 4
by 4, you get 1.
This 4 by 4, you get 1.
So now when you multiply it, you
get 9 times 1, which is 9,
over 1 times 7, which is 7.
So we have our answer,
but right now,
it's an improper fraction.
They want us to write it
as a mixed number.
And to figure it out as a mixed
number, we can do it in
our heads now.
I think we've seen this
enough times.
We say how many times
does 7 go into 9?
Well, it goes into it exactly
one time, but when you take 7
into 9 one time, what do
you have left over?
Well, you're going to have
2 left over, right?
7 times 1 is 7, and you're going
to have 2 left over.
You need 2 more to get to 9.
So you're going to have 2 left
over, so this is 1 and 2/7.
And we're done!